Friendship Day, celebrated on the first Sunday in August,...
...is a special day for celebrating the role of friends in one's life...
...and for paying tribute to them.
You will need: remembrance, a friend from another country, cards, flowers, or gifts,...
...a wristband or bracelet, Winnie the Pooh and a party.
Step one: Reach out to a friend in another country.
Friendship Day is now an international event.
Step two: Exchange cards with friends.
It's also traditional to exchange flowers and gifts.
Gift card companies often have promotional campaigns at the time of Friendship Day.
Step three: Exchange friendship wristbands with a special friend.
Girls also exchange friendship bracelets.
Step four: Locate a copy of A. A. Milne's children's book "Winnie the Pooh."
In 1997, the United Nations declared Pooh the world's ambassador of friendship.
Step five: Throw a party.
Friendship Day is often celebrated by young people with boisterous parties.
And while friendship is not just for the young,...
...having a youthful spirit can help in any celebration among friends.
Did you know?
American philosopher Ralph Waldo Emerson once wrote,...
..."The only way to have a friend is to be one."